I think I was about seven years old when
I wrote my first line of code it was
probably something simple printing my
name to the screen or a two-dimensional
shape that could be twisted and
stretched by my sequence of carefully
typed letters and digits it was an
extraordinary feeling a first sense of
where the logic defining power of the
computer could take us but it wasn't
until much later that I started to come
across the term artificial intelligence
or AI and well what a world that would
open up AI holds enormous promise for
the future and I think these are
incredibly exciting times to sort of be
alive and working in these fields we
want to kind of understand and master
increasingly complex systems AI must be
build responsibly and safely and used
for the benefit of everyone in society
and we have to ensure the benefits
accrue to everyone you know I think AI
can be one of the most exciting and
transformative technologies we'll ever
invent that is the voice of demis
hassabis the CEO of deepmind the
london-based
artificial intelligence company for
demos ai will allow us to create
computer systems that can learn to solve
complex problems by themselves in his
words society could use intelligence to
solve everything else cancer climate
change language energy in short to
advance scientific discovery but just
how far-fetched are these goals can
researchers really crack intelligence
and just how much of an impact would
that really have I'm Hanna Frey and this
is deep mind the podcast for the past
year I've been at deep mind HQ in London
for an inside look at the fascinating
world of AI research and where it's
going we will be telling you the
fast-moving story of the biggest
challenges in artificial intelligence or
AI so whether you just want to know more
about where the technology is headed all
want to be inspired on your own AI
journey then you've come to the right
place we will focus on the projects that
scientists researchers and engineers are
actually working on how they're
approaching the science of AI and some
of the tricky decisions the whole field
is wrestling with at the moment and
whilst we're here we've explored the
rooms full of computer screens where
scientists run their endless experiments
the meeting rooms where people write
intricate equations on whiteboards
packed to the rafters the robots and the
laboratories where banks of repetitive
robot arms grapple with piles of plastic
bricks and we've talked to a huge number
of people to try to understand what is
driving this new frontier the voices
that you'll hear in this podcast are
from the people that are at the cutting
edge of AI and machine learning and
quite a few of them are talking about
their work publicly for the very first
time but if we want to solve
intelligence let's start with a
fundamental question of AI what exactly
do we mean by intelligence if we're
trying to make machines intelligent what
are we actually aiming for this is sort
of something that's debated a lot in AI
world is like well do we want to you
know have our AI agents act exactly the
same way that people do like should they
be exactly human-like intelligent or
should they just be intelligent in
general
this is Jess Hamrick a research
scientist at deep mind her specialism is
imagination and mental simulation
there's sort of I guess like you know
one group of people who like to say that
you know we want to build something
that's just generally intelligent that's
really able to solve a lot of different
problems in the world that humans aren't
necessarily able to solve that has an
intelligence that's higher than humans
so this might be able to solve problems
like how do we cure all diseases like
maybe maybe and artificial intelligence
might be able to help us solve this
problem and that's you know something
human society and human civilization
hasn't yet been able to accomplish but
then there's also another group of
people who say that it's really
important for us to build AI that is
similar to human intelligence at least
in some ways I would consider myself to
be sort of in the latter group why does
it need to be similar to human the
reason is because as we build AI we as
humans need to be able to interact with
AI and collaborate with it be able to
understand the predictions that it's
making or the recommendations that it's
making and if we build AI in a way that
is maybe we are able to build AI and
it's generally intelligent but it acts
in a way that's so alien to humans that
we just can't really understand what
it's doing and I think that actually
would be a really bad scenario to be in
because either it means that people
don't trust it and then people are very
unwilling to you know use the
recommendations of this AI maybe it says
oh do this one thing and this will like
cure this disease and but people don't
understand why it's making that
recommendation maybe we miss out on a
lot of opportunities to really do a lot
of good in the world
we need Rai to understand the world in
the same way that we do it needs to be
able to explain itself to us so we can
be sure that we can trust it take for
instance the story of an AI that was
trained to diagnose skin cancer by
looking at photographs of skin lesions
taken by dermatologists the algorithm
did a good job of correctly labeling the
images but the researchers soon
discovered that the AI wasn't looking at
the cancer at all to make its decision
it had simply learned that lesions
photographed next to a ruler are more
likely to be malignant
not exactly trustworthy it's crucially
important that artificial intelligence
is able to grasp the subtleties of human
thoughts we want it to do what we mean
it to do not just what we say we mean
but that doesn't necessarily imply it
nice to think in exactly the same way as
people do there can be drawbacks to
trying to imitate human or animal brains
too closely we get into discussions
about where the strategy can limit you
this is Matt Banach Matt is the director
of neuroscience research at deep mind
where he draws on his experience in
cognitive neuroscience and experimental
psychology Matt believes the human mind
is the inspiration but AI research has
to take things further in its own way
you know the Wright brothers when they
solved the problem of flight you know
that people like to say oh they solved
the problem when they stopped trying to
copy bird's wings which you know in some
technical way might be true but they
wouldn't have gotten to where they were
right if they hadn't spend an awful lot
of time and if other people hadn't spent
an awful lot of time looking at bird's
wings and noticing the airfoil pattern
and thinking about the the dynamics of
the of the air that flows around an
object with this shape so yeah we we do
believe that we can look to the human
brain in the human mind for inspiration
but we also talk about them when the
moment comes where we need to kind of
step away from that and just build
something that does what we want it to
do
so what is the neuroscience equivalent
what are the birds wings of our brains
the aspects of our own intelligence that
we can use for inspiration as we build
AI well one area that seems to hold a
lot of promise is memory and in
particular something we all do known as
we play replay as a phenomenon that was
discovered in a part of the mammalian
brain the medial temporal lobe including
the hippocampus where you see neural
activity that suggests that past
experiences are being replayed
especially in in navigation for example
a rat will go through some environment
and a particular pattern of activity
will arise as it goes through the
environment and then later if you have
electrodes in the hippocampus you can
see that the same pattern of activity
the same sequence is occurring
suggesting that a memory is being
replayed of that experience and that
idea now has a firm place in AI if you
lose your car keys you can run your mind
through where you've been to workout
where you might have left them well I
first went into the kitchen and took my
coat off in the hallway put my bag down
on the side and oh yeah they're in my
back pocket that ability to replay your
experiences and learn from that memory
after the fact is a key part of what
researchers want AI to be able to do
here's more from that the way that
that's implemented in deep minds agents
is it's not exactly what you find in the
brain it wasn't as if people were trying
to slavishly recreate the the biological
mechanisms but the idea of replay which
was inspired by neuroscience came in
handy
in 2015 replay
played a pivotal role in a famous
deepmind breakthrough the team managed
to build an AI system that could play
arcade classics to a superhuman level
the old Atari games like space invaders
pong and breakout the AI use something
called deep reinforcement learning but
behind the scenes it kept a memory of
moves it made as it played and how those
moves had impacted on the final score by
replaying those memories the AI could
learn from his experiences it could work
out what sequences of moves worked well
which were mistakes and find strategies
that otherwise wouldn't have been
obvious but there's more to our human
memories than just a giant database of
facts of course you can remember the
name of the capital of France but you
might also be able to remember jumping
on the bouncy castle at your 6th
birthday party or the pranks you played
on your last day at school this is a
phenomenon called episodic memory and
it's something that holds a great deal
of promise for AI we talk a lot about
something called episodic memory which
is simply the cognitive ability to
retrieve a memory of something that
happened to you before we started
recording we were joking about like what
did you have for breakfast
your ability to cast your mind back to
that moment when you were eating
breakfast and retrieve that information
that's a function that psychologists and
neuroscientists refer to as episodic
memory and we have this category both
because psychologists work hard over
decades to fractionate memory into
particular domains or kinds but this is
a pretty high-level idea it's not like
replay it's just hey there's such a
thing as episodic memory which is very
important for human intelligence
maybe our agents should have episodic
memory what would that mean what would
it mean for an artificial agent to have
episodic memory
this is an intriguing possibility an AI
that can transport itself back in time
and recall entire events and experiences
rather than just facts when you stop and
think about it this ability to link one
memory with another is an amazing human
skill and if researchers can get a
better understanding of how our brains
actually do this it could be replicated
in AI systems giving them a much greater
capacity for solving novel problems
let's think about how that works for a
moment imagine that every morning you
see the same man in his thirties walking
a boisterous collie then one day a
white-haired lady who looks like the man
comes down the street with the same dog
with those events stored as episodes in
your mind you might immediately make a
series of deductions the man and the
woman might come from the same household
the lady maybe the man's mother or
another close relative perhaps she's
taken over his role because he's ill or
busy we weave an intricate story of
these strangers pulling material from
our memories together prioritizing some
pieces of information over others to
make it coherent it's something that's
been the focus of recent research by the
neuroscientists here a study in
September 2018 demonstrated the critical
role of the hippocampus that shrimp
shaped seat of memory in the middle of
the brain in weaving together individual
memories to produce new insight Jess
Hamrick is also looking at another way
that a eyes can be made to respond more
flexibly to new situations she takes our
inspiration from a different human
ability mental simulation what you and I
might call imagination imagine that
you're on a beach you'll have like this
mental picture kind of spring to mind of
you know mine at least is maybe a sandy
beach the bright blue ocean maybe some
palm trees on the slope
and so this is an example of what we
would call mental simulation it's like
we're mentally stimulating this picture
of the beach and then you can do things
with that simulation so you can imagine
adding other people to your imagination
you can imagine what would happen if you
like threw a ball if you're playing
volleyball or something like that so
these these sort of mental simulations
are really interactive and really rich
and I think that they underlie a lot of
our human ability to understand the
world and make predictions about the
world I should pause for a moment here
to explain what Jess and maps mean by an
age in here it's a word that's used a
lot at deep mind remember when people
are talking about artificial
intelligence they're really just talking
about computer code with the freedom to
make its own decisions and an agent is
just the noun that they use to describe
the part of that code that has agency
Jeff's is hoping to build agents that
are flexible enough to adapt to all
manner of environments it's a very grand
ambition but one with real potential to
see why let's go back to the RKO and
like game of space invaders mastered
using deep reinforcement learning to
create an agent called deep Q network or
dqn dqn was really sort of an amazing
technological feat because it was able
to be trained to play many many
different Atari games directly from
perception from pixels this is something
that hadn't been done before
but the way that dqn also works is that
it really just goes directly from inputs
to output so it takes in the image of
the video game and outputs immediately
what actions should be taken to maximize
the score in that game so maybe it's a
move left maybe it's you know push the
trigger to shoot all of these actions
are being taken just to maximize that
score and the agent doesn't know why
that action is good it only knows this
action will give me a higher score and
so the agent isn't able to really do
anything else besides that you can't ask
the agent to say hide behind one of the
pillars until that pillar is destroyed
or destroy all of the incoming space
invaders in one line and none of the
other space invaders so these are all
kinds of like different tasks that you
could give a human and they may
a little bit weird but humans would
understand what what it means to do this
and that's because humans have this
ability for mental simulation to imagine
what will happen if they take different
actions and so by giving our agents the
ability to imagine things and also plan
according to different tasks that it
might be given they're able to act more
flexibly and deal with these sort of
novel situations but humans aren't the
only form of intelligence we can draw
inspiration from we can also learn from
our cousins in the animal kingdom
let's bring in researcher Greg Wayne
within neuroscience
Greg's thing is memory and cognitive
architecture one of the things that is
quite clear is that animals have a
remarkable ability to deal with for
example very long time scales so
experiences that can be linked across
periods of time that is way beyond our
our current sets of agents the great
example I think is the scrub Jay the
Western scrub Jay they bury things they
prepare for the winter by scrounging up
a lot of food and putting it into
depositing different places hiding it
from each other and they love to steal
each other's food - they're scavengers
and they can remember thousands of sites
where they've they buried their food so
once all at once and they they can even
no detailed facts about it they know how
long ago they buried things that they
know if they were being washed while
they're burying things they know what
thing they buried there they have an
incredible memory for these events that
they have produced themselves how can
you tell that they know what they buried
because they have a preference you'll
see that they'll they like maggots more
than peanuts they'll go back to those
maggots first
having a kind of large database of
things that you've done and seen that
you can access and that you can use to
then guide your your goal-directed
behavior later you know I'm hungry mmm I
would love to have some maggots right
now where should I go find those that's
that's the kind of thing we would like
to replicate and there's another big
lesson we can learn from animals if you
want to teach dog to sit you don't write
a list of instructions move this muscle
bend your leg 45 degrees anything like
that instead you repeat the same task
over and over again offering punishments
and rewards as you go and if it's good
you give it a little bit of food that's
how we train dogs now I have a friend
who trains dogs to do things on iPads
using reinforcement learning so we've
already started on the path in AI of
merging reinforcement learning very
closely with how our AI is make
decisions and so on and that's how we
train them so you're essentially
training an artificial intelligence an
AI in the same way that you might train
a dog rewarding them for good behavior
ignoring that behavior very nice okay
how do you treat an AI what does it mean
to reward something that isn't
interested in doggy biscuits
here's dem assess Arbus well with
artificial systems or they really care
about is ones and zeros so you can
construct artificial reward mechanisms
for almost anything we've now moved away
from programming the system solution so
it now learns for itself so now going up
a meta level so now what we're really
programming or designing is reward
systems so it's kind of interesting that
that now is becoming the difficult part
is like how do you design curricula how
do you design breadcrumb trails or
rewards so that eventually they learn
the right things these systems but
there's also the idea of unsupervised
learning which is how do you learn
things if in the absence of any reward
and actually that's the issue with
reward learning in the real world as
humans or even as children there aren't
very many rewards it's quite sparse the
rewards even as a dog right the dog gets
a doggie biscuit every now and again but
has to decide every moment like what to
do and actually I think one of the
answer to that is what we call intrinsic
motivation which is internal drives that
have come through in animals have come
from evolution but we could also evolve
or build in those drives are very strong
and they guide the animal or the system
even in the absence of external rewards
so of course that might be things like
joy or fear or even things like hunger
these are all primal kind of internal
motivations that drive your behavior
even in the absence of any external
reward you're listening to deep mind the
podcast a window on AI research while
rewards might be a key part of how to
encourage AI to learn one of the main
aims of machine learning is for AI to be
able to teach itself to notice patterns
and shortcuts between tasks and make
themselves more efficient learners in an
ideal world engineers would like to
reach a point where AI can learn in a
similar way to humans picking up the
essentials of a new task in a matter of
minutes back to mat botnik an example
would be I went on holiday recently to
South America and I wanted to brush up
my Spanish and I knew exactly how to do
that I knew what resources were out
there for to begin with but more
importantly when I sat down to brush up
my Spanish I had a whole repertoire of
concepts that really guided me like I
know what it means to conjugate a verb
right I know that in certain languages
there are masculine to feminine forms so
this background knowledge helped me
learn much more rapidly than if I just
sort of was dumped into the middle of
you know a new language without
understanding what it means to learn a
language and we want systems we want
artificial systems that come armed with
these concepts it's not just about
language it could be video games we
could sit down in front of a new video
game that you've never played but if
you've played video games in the past
you kind of know how video games work
and that helps you to learn rapidly
the AI is what's known as narrow in its
focus now that might be diagnosing
cancer or playing video games but the
ultimate goal is to create something
much more powerful something called
artificial general intelligence with
precisely this ability of being able to
adapt to different situations to be able
to use the high-level concepts it's
learned in one environment and apply
them in another we don't want just a
system that's it's really good at one
thing we want a system that's really
good at lots of things but really what
we mean is we want a system that can
pick up new tasks that it's never
performed before we want an intelligence
where you say ok you've never solved
this kind of problem before but let me
let me tell you what I want you to think
about now and you could introduce them
to organic chemistry or something and
they would be able to work with that
humans can do this but getting machines
to do this is really really tricky and
it's not the only thing that we humans
can do that AI finds hard Gregg spends a
lot of his time trying to understand the
detailed mental processes behind
apparently simple human tasks you have
breakfast and you drink your orange
juice and you run out and then you think
to yourself god when I leave work I'm
gonna have to pick up some art shoes you
go through your workday you don't even
think about orange juice once and then
it springs to mind you know immediately
as you're leaving the office that you
need to go pick up some large juice when
you are going to buy the orange juice it
is actually of no value to your present
self the only self that will benefit
from buying the orange juice is yourself
at breakfast the next day so you're
actually you have to do something that
is incredibly prospective or thinking
forward thinking about the context of
your future self this is something I
mean people here really sit around and
sort of talk about and try and work out
what is it about your brain that reminds
you to buy orange juice at the right
moment yes because you can easily
construct virtual environments with
tasks for agents that we normally have
that have properties like this like
thinking minutes or hours ahead or
remember
something from hours ago that our normal
agents completely stumble on they cannot
do why is that they seem easy seems easy
to buy orange juice there's a theme
emerging here back in the 1980s hands
Moravec and his colleagues pointed out
that when it comes to artificial
intelligence everything is a little bit
upside down while the things that humans
find tough like maths and chess and data
crunching require very little
computation the things that we humans
manage without even thinking turn out to
be monumentally difficult for machines
it's a phenomenon that has become known
as more of X paradox like other
neuroscientists and psychologists here I
I find myself thinking about stuff that
seems really simple stuff that I do and
other people do really without thinking
about it and it just doesn't seem that
big a deal but it turns out to be those
some of those things turn out to be very
difficult to engineer into artificial
systems so picking things up putting
things down planning a route through a
building things that we can just do
without really much mental effort
sometimes proved to be quite difficult
to engineer an example of this just came
up as we walked into this room we all
realize that it was quite stuffy in here
and that we wanted to try to cool it
down so we all huddled around the
thermostat and tried to figure out how
to get it to do what we wanted and it
seemed to be resistant and at some
moment I thought wait a minute maybe
maybe the air conditionings just broken
and again that seems like a super simple
thing like you know what's such a big
deal about that but actually in AI
research we have a name for this which
is latent state inference we're trying
to infer some aspect of what's going on
which is latent or hidden and it turns
out in order to do that seemingly simple
thing you need a very rich model of the
world you need to understand air
conditioners and thermostats and what it
means to be broken and what's the
probability that it's broken and so
forth more of a paradox is often talked
about as some kind of profound mystery
it's used as evidence that while the
jobs of animal
some lawyers might be at risk in an age
of AI gardeners receptionist's and cooks
are secure in their careers for decades
to come
but deep mines founder demis hassabis
has quite a different take I think it's
quite obvious as a simple explanation
for it
when Marivic was doing AI the dominant
paradigm was expert systems so hand
crafting solutions directly to AI
problems think of it as building big
databases of rules of course if you're
going to do that that in itself is a
very explicit task programming that out
you know you have to know exactly what
you want to write and what rules you
want to incorporate and what that means
is the only tasks you can do that with
are the ones that you explicitly know
how to do as humans yourself and that's
things like the logical based like maths
and chess so weirdly the things that we
do intuitively ourselves and
effortlessly like walking and seeing and
you know all of these sort of sensory
motor skills seems effortless to us and
the reason is is because there's
actually huge amounts of brain
processing is going into that it's just
that it's subconscious its areas of the
brain we don't have conscious access to
we probably knew less about neuroscience
at the time so we didn't realize quite
how much processing goes on in the
visual cortex for example and so now we
know both of those things we know how
the brain works better and we've built
learning systems like alpha zero and
alphago so it turns out actually vision
is not any more difficult really than
playing go it's similar if you approach
it in the same way it's almost
impossible to reverse-engineer our
unconscious skills using the old methods
of handcrafted programming you have to
have a total and complete conscious
understanding of how something worked
before you could ask a computer to
replicate it but now the machines are
just beginning to mimic our subconscious
processes like vision and pattern
recognition there's no reason why more
of X paradox needs to necessarily be a
barrier in the future
[Music]
I have to be honest with you this single
idea more than any I've learned in
making this series is the one hit home
and underlines the power and potential
of AI for me all that we've managed so
far in everything that we've created
with machines are only the things that
we consciously know how to order them to
perform we're only just at the very
beginning of artificially mimicking our
subconscious processes - and that means
that there is an extremely exciting
journey ahead
but this partnership of studying
neuroscience and artificial intelligence
alongside one another doesn't just help
make our AI better
here's Matt Botvinnik and Jess Hamrick
again to explain we often talk here
about the virtuous cycle the opposite of
a vicious cycle right there's a virtuous
cycle between AI and neuroscience where
neuroscience
helps AI along and then AI like returns
the favor one of the reasons why we can
get this virtuous cycle between
neuroscience and cognitive science and
AI is because fundamentally we're all
trying to study the same thing which is
intelligence and so if we ask sort of
these more abstract questions about what
should an intelligence system do in this
situation we can ask that about humans
what would a person do in this situation
and try to come up with an answer we
could ask what should our a AI agent do
in this situation and try to come up
with an answer or if we have an answer
already in one of those fields we can
take the solution and apply it to one of
the other fields and I think that's sort
of really what enables this this ability
to transfer between the different fields
[Music]
this isn't just a theoretical flow of
ideas there are real examples of ideas
from artificial intelligence finding
their way back into neuroscience so
there's a neurotransmitter a chemical
that conveys messages in the brain
called dopamine in the 1990s people were
finding ways of tracking the release of
dopamine in the brain and very clear
patterns were being identified but
nobody really understood what they meant
why does the brain release dopamine in
this situation and not that situation
and as I understand the history some
papers hit the desk of some people who
were studying computational
reinforcement learning people like Peter
Dayan and Reed Montagu and they just saw
immediately that the the patterns of
activity that were being reported in
these neuroscience papers the dopamine
data could be explained by the math
that's involved in reinforcement
learning that has led to a real
revolution in the neuroscience of
learning
if you give a monkey a treat they get a
little heat of dopamine in their brains
it's the same in our brains too a little
burst of pleasure whenever something
good happens but in the 1990s
researchers realized that dopamine
wasn't actually the response to the
reward it was reporting back about the
difference between what the monkey
expected the reward to be and what it
actually received if you're walking down
the road and you unexpectedly find a 20
pound note it's much more exciting than
if you're collecting a 20 pound nose
that's owed to you by a friend and if a
monkey is expecting you to give it a
grape and you hand it a piece of
cucumber it's gonna be a lot less happy
than if you just surprised it with a bit
of cucumber from nowhere thing is AI
researchers were already using something
that acted in a very similar way in
their algorithms they'd get their agents
to make a prediction about what was
going to happen next and compare it to
what actually occurred but remember in
all of this the idea is to just take
inspiration from the way that our human
brains work not to make a
straightforward artificial copy because
our brains on exactly perfect
so we've heard how we can take
inspiration from the human brain from
the animal and even the bird brain to
create AI systems but this isn't just a
working theory anymore researchers
aren't just talking about what they want
to do they're also talking about what
they've actually managed to do let me
tease you with car I cover cholo
director of research at deep mind it's a
simple problem of course you can write a
program to solve that but the idea was
try to do deep reinforcement learning
try to come up with a system that we
think can generalize to different
problems more problems and once we saw
that it was a matter of weeks we had ten
or fifteen Atari games being solved if
you would like to find out more about
the link between AI and the brain or
explore the world of AI research beyond
deep mind you'll find plenty of useful
links in the show notes for each episode
and if there are stories or sources that
you think other listeners would find
helpful then let us know you can message
us on Twitter or email the team at
podcast that deepmind comm you can also
use that address to send us your
questions or feedback on the series
let's take a little breather see you
shortly